looking for a job as a makeup artist
teaching ballroom dancing or blow drying
hair in some parts of the country you'll
need government certification before
anyone can pay you for these services or
face jail time occupational licensing
laws which apply to one in three US jobs
restrict consumer choice by protecting
businesses from competition they also
impose substantial costs on jobseekers
Arizona has one of the nation's most
heavily regulated labor markets but now
the state's businessman governor Doug
Ducey who's the former CEO of Cold Stone
Creamery has made occupational licensing
reform a priority what I wanted Arizona
to be is the best place in the country
to live work and do business and part of
that is beginning a business as well as
scaling a business and that was our
focus on improving that that structure
of government and really stopping the
the bullies that were part of the boards
and commissions
since occupational licensing laws are
particular to each state if you're a
certified hairdryer say in Virginia that
doesn't mean you can move to Arizona and
just start working first you have to
complete a thousand hours of training
before you can obtain a state
cosmetology license Governor Ducey is
backing a new law that would change that
just because somebody packs up that
moving van in Chicago Illinois they
don't lose their skills on the way to
the state of Arizona so why should
somebody have to suffer a burden of
thousands of dollars or weeks or months
of recertification in a skill that they
already have we had a tough time
figuring out how many regulations there
are in the state of Arizona with a
crackerjack staff it took us probably 18
months to figure out there were 11,000
regulations in the state in 2017 Ducey
issued an executive order requiring that
state licensing boards review and
provide justification for rules the
governor's office deemed excessive the
next day he signed the right to earn a
living Act which restricted state boards
from issuing any new occupational
licensing rules that couldn't be
justified on health and safety grounds I
think it's important that we remember
who the voters are and who the citizens
are and we're here to serve them too
many of these boards and commissions
exist
you stopped competition to stifle and
protect the status quo and we're
changing that in Arizona my issue is
that we don't really know what the
standards are in these other states and
so why should we dumb down our standards
just to deregulate basically I mean I
see this as sort of deregulation for the
sake of deregulation representative
Pamela powers hanley of Tucson is
opposed to the legislation what I see
here is you know over and over and over
again you know throwing out licenses and
certifications and there was other bills
that were proposed in the house this
year that would go even farther than
this as far as deregulating deregulating
occupations and I think at some point it
gets a little risky for the populace how
so I mean because if you have if you're
successful in another state doing this I
mean it's not like those skills don't
stop when you come into this day
well yes but with this we're only asking
for one year of experience I mean what
what's the definition of successful and
then also how are we checking up on
these people what about this idea of
public safety because I do think there's
a fear that you're actually going to
attract people from states that have
lower standards than Arizona public
health and public safety is always going
to be a priority for this administration
we're going to work with the individuals
that are coming and with the licensing
boards in which they came from to make
sure that we're making good decisions
but I'm confident with the legislation
we have with the guardrails and details
that it involves that will be bringing
qualified people here and then
ultimately it will be the opportunities
that will determine their success
Arizona's over regulated labor market
through public attention in 2017 when it
came out that a student barber named
Juan Carlos Montes de oka was being
investigated by the state cosmetology
board for giving haircuts to homeless
vets without a license the bullies at
the state cosmetology board sought to
stop him and stall his career because he
hadn't yet kissed their ring and we
thought he was just doing it
good act for people that were in need
and this was a young person just in the
formative years of their career we
thought that was the wrong thing to do
and we were very pleasantly surprised by
the response that we received from the
electorate saying yes we don't need this
overreach we don't need this
over-regulation the new bill recognising
out of state certification recently
passed the House and is currently under
consideration in the state Senate we
still have to prove it in the
marketplace we still need to get it
through both houses of the legislature
Ducey credits his deregulatory agenda
for Arizona's booming economy we're the
fourth fastest growing state in the
nation Maricopa County where we are here
in greater Phoenix is the number one
fastest growing County in America two
years running we're a state that has 70%
of the adults here were born somewhere
other than the state of Arizona I don't
think that there's a better leading
indicator in this country then that
people pack up a u-haul truck and say
that's where I want to move to and the
game of states people vote with their
feet and theirs on his winning
[Music]